all right y'all ready for a show
when you're on the stage and you're
giving it your all and the show comes to
an end
and you know that you've left everything
on the stage that is the most rewarding
feeling
[Applause]
i am byron hannah the step master of the
sigma here at north carolina ent to be
the step master is to be that person
that
creates the steps bring it back to the
team and teach everyone how to do these
steps
seven is a combination of clapping and
stumping in a particular rhythm
it comes from africa
stepping serves a huge role in
historically black greek organizations
and these organizations were founded in
the early 1900s they were put together
to make a more powerful force in the
community
seven is something that fraternities and
sororities brought to the current day
the step show was one of the main events
at g-ho which stands for the greatest
homecoming on earth it brings in
thousands of thousands of people we have
been winning the step show for 11 years
straight when fraternities and
sororities go on the stage there is so
much to lose reputation respect
so the pressure for
the sigma is winning 11 consecutive
years is crazy
you know where you need to be
as the step master i serve as the coach
the captain
team member
all these things in one person the
biggest pressure that is on my back is
maintaining that legacy
to become a good stepper it is very very
difficult it's something that you really
got to give all your dedication to
so the stump so loud
clap so loud and scream so loud
it's an opportunity to let loose it's
very very therapeutic
that's why we usually do
the face it's the face of disgust and we
do that to push out more energy and push
out more anger
you are destroying your body
on concrete pavement day in and day out
for four months uh some nights i walk
away from the pockets limping sometimes
we have the mentality that okay
we already won 11 years in a row so you
know what's another year going to do but
one thing that we have to keep in mind
is that we can't lose
[Music]
so the night of the step show being
backstage i feel like i'm ready for it
and i feel like my team is ready for it
a lot of older brothers come back there
you know give encouraging words so close
the show out with excitement and with a
bang and the time was counting down
i had to go run off into the corner and
actually had to cry
those tears weren't sadness something
that had to bring me back to where i was
and prepare me to go out on the stage
[Music]
i legit
left everything that i had on that stage
we are waiting on
the judges to calculate up the scores
just to know that the legacy is on the
line right now all right let's get to
these winners
first
undefeated
[Applause]
we won
i'm proud of every single person because
it's been a long journey and now they're
part of a legacy
[Music]
you